intercommunalité intercommunalité
intercommunalité
je t'ai rabâcher les oreilles en te
parlant d'intercommunalité durant toute
la dernière vidéo et je sais ce que tu
te dis moi j'habite pas dans une
intercommunalité mais dans une
communauté de communes ou dans une
métropole
sauf que est ta communauté de communes
c'est une intercommunalité est à
métropole aussi tu es perdu je
t'explique alors vu que tu regarde avec
attention nos vidéos
tu sais que pour réaliser certaines
prestations ou réaliser certains projets
les communes peuvent joindre leurs
compétences et une partie de leur budget
c'est ce qu'on appelle une
intercommunalité ou le pci
mais tu sais aussi que lors de nos
précédentes vidéos on n'avait pas
détaillé les différentes
intercommunalités et ça on va le faire
maintenant
tout d'abord il ya deux catégories
d'intercommunalité les opci à fiscalité
propre et les opci sans fiscalité propre
en gros si une pci à une fiscalité
propre
ça veut dire que dans nos impôts locaux
il y à une partie qui est reversée
directement à l'intercommunalité si elle
n'a pas de fiscalité propre
alors c'est la commune qui va reverser
de l'argent à l'intercommunalité pour
réaliser les tâches de la collectivité
le pci sans fiscalité propre s'appelle
un syndicat de communes le syndicat de
communes et le plus souvent mis en place
pour réaliser des petites opérations qui
ont un intérêt pour toutes les communes
du syndicat
l'étape au-dessus de le pci sans
fiscalité propre et tu leur as deviné le
pci avec fiscalité propre
la plus petite des opci à fiscalité
propre et la communauté de communes
c'est un groupe de communes qui au sein
d'un espace d'un seul tenant doit
regrouper au moins 15000 habitants au
dessus de la communauté de communes on
trouve la communauté d'agglomération
elle doit au moins regrouper 50000
habitants avec au moins une commune
importante
certaines compétences de la commune sont
automatiquement transférées à la
communauté de communes ou à la
communauté d'agglomération et certaines
autres sont optionnelles et choisis par
les intercommunalités elle même au
dessus de la communauté d'agglomération
on retrouve la communauté urbaine qui
doit cette fois ci comptait au moins 250
mille habitants et qui se retrouvent
avec encore plus de compétences
obligatoires
enfin au dessus de la communauté urbaine
on trouve la métropole regroupement
géant qui doit avoir au moins quatre
cent mille habitants
il se trouve que presque toutes les
grandes villes de france sont des
métropoles et c'est évidemment le pci
qui possède le plus de compétences elle
peut même en récupérer du département de
la région ou de l'état après accord
par contre attention attention la
métropole le lion n'est pas une
métropole comme les autres elle n'est
pas juste une intercommunalité mais
c'est une collectivité territoriale à
statut particulier il faut aussi savoir
que les intercommunalités peuvent aussi
travailler entre elles c'est ce qu'on
appelle des pôles métropolitains
donc voilà on a fait le tour avec des
intercommunalités
j'espère que lorsque tu iras voter en
2020 pour ta commune et intercommunalité
tu sauras un peu mieux démêlés qui et
quoi en tout cas merci d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo jusqu'au bout laissez nous
un commentaire et un pouce en l'air six
a dit tu peux nous aider avec notre tipi
ou en devenant membre de notre
association on se retrouve bientôt pour
une nouvelle vidéo
à bientôt